the memes were stuff like Ben swallow
and amazing everything you said was just
said was wrong and of course the pores
they worried the spoilers its I'm sorry
man I hate it's okay excuse me I have
somebody I have to kill okay all right
I'll talk about stuff while you go like
beat up your roommate or whatever so
anyway uh yeah lots of stuff going on in
my life lately I got that new job I've
been trying to make ends meet
I have a girlfriend now I think I talked
about her a couple weeks back on the
podcast I don't know if we were dating
officially yet back then but she's
really cool
she lives kind of far but she's gonna
come visit me soon hopefully in the next
week or two God David's got a whole
thing going on over there anyway uh so I
want to do a stream this Sunday to raise
funds for my girlfriend's trip here
because cash is kind of kind of tight
right now
because I just barely started this
second job and I'm you know trying to
because I also have a lot of other
expenses I'm trying to pay for like I
have to get my license plates changed
out before the end of this month I uh I
have a lot of medical bills I got to pay
because I went to the hospital a couple
of week couple months ago I wasn't
wasn't feeling too well and [ __ ]
hospital bills are a pain in the ass and
then her expenses for her trip or a lot
and then I also want to get another bed
that's bigger for two people so the goal
is this Sunday is I'm gonna do like a
fundraiser stream and we're gonna try
and just raise as much money as we can
of just extra cash for her trip here I'm
gonna have my buddies Brandon and Joey
coming along for the ride we're gonna
play a couple of different games we're
gonna try and we're gonna look at
fanart live and kind of discuss it we're
gonna have a tournament and injustice
we're gonna try and play with some fans
on DC Universe Online we're gonna we we
want to do this this segment where we do
bad comic art but live and just see how
how that goes you're saying anything
important it's gonna be cut out please I
actually really need you to leave that
in just I mean I'm sure you'll know when
you're editing this I won't anyway don't
well please don't cut it then no god
damn it I'm now in my stream for Sunday
cuz I want to raise funds for a couple
of my bills and then also to be able to
fly my girlfriend out here I'm just
saying this probably isn't the best
place to announce that because nobody
actually was decent amount of people
will watch it we'll listen to this so
unless you want to avoid an announcement
for your own channel and upload it and
that's gonna what if we cut out this
this segment of the podcast on my
recording and then just upload that to
my channel so I don't have to do two
separate videos when I think people
would be more likely to watch it if you
filmed yourself saying it but I mean
this works okay yeah I gotta have like a
big clique baby thumbnail of my face and
then like like some kind of like dumbass
meme headline like godzilla mendoza
needs your help or else he'll die and
then like a picture of me lying in a
hospital bed or something or a picture
of me getting shot something youtube
would really like I mean he loved death
I love that they love violence